hello everyone this screencast is going
to be a brief playthrough of homework
one on word relatedness i hope to give
you a sense for the problem that you're
tackling and also our expectations
around the homework questions and the
bake off so let's dive in here
the overview is just explaining the
character of this problem which is
essentially that we're going to give you
a development set of word pairs with
scores and the scores reflect
relatedness the scores were produced by
humans and we've just scaled them into
zero to one
where a larger score means more related
in this human sense and your task is
essentially to develop a system that
will predict scores that are highly
correlated with those human scores
according to the spearman correlation
coefficient which is the traditional
metric in this space
so this is just some setup stuff for the
environment and then we introduce the
development set itself which is a
panda's data frame it's loaded in from
your data folder
and it looks like this it's got a bunch
of word pairs each with scores as i said
before these are the human provided
scores this is a development data set in
the sense that you can make whatever use
you want of it you can train systems you
can explore your results and so forth
because as you'll see for the actual
bake off we have a fresh test set that
you'll make predictions on
there are about 5 000 words in this
development set
um you can train on any subset and you
can expand the data set to other things
if you want to include them as well it's
really up to you to decide what you want
to do because this is all about making
predictions on that brand new test set
as you'll see later
and i will just say that the test set
has 1500 word pairs with scores of the
same type
and in terms of the overlap i'll also
tell you no word pair in this
development set is in the test set so
it's disjoint at the level of these
pairs but some of the individual words
are repeated in the test sets you do
have some vocabulary overlap
in this code here we load the full
vocabulary for this thing which is you
know all the words appearing in all the
pairs
the vocabulary for the bake off test is
different it's partially overlapping
with the above as i said now if you
wanted to make sure ahead of time that
your system has a representation for
every word in both the dev and the test
sets then you can check against the
vocabularies in any of the vector space
models that we've distributed with this
unit
so for example if you ran this code you
get the full task vocabulary and if you
have a representation for every word in
there then you're good shape in good
shape when it comes to the test set
it's also useful to look at the score
distribution this will give you a sense
for what kind of space you're making
predictions into and i'll give you the
hint that the test distribution looks an
awful lot like this dev set distribution
it's also worth being aware that there
are some repeated pairs in the training
set some words that have different
scores associated with them and they're
repeated therefore what i've done here
is just provide you with some code that
will allow you to rank pairs of words by
the variance in their scores and so you
could decide for yourself what you want
to do about these minor inconsistencies
you could filter the data set or keep
all of these examples in it's entirely
up to you i will just say that the test
set does not force you to confront this
issue it has no repeated pairs in it
all right and then we come to the
evaluation topic here so there's a
central function you'll be using a lot
in the homework and the bake off word
related and disevaluation
and so there are some instructions about
how the interface works let me just give
a brief illustration
in this cell i'm loading in one of our
count matrices it's the giga5 matrix
and i'm going to evaluate that directly
so you can see in the next cell that
word relatedness evaluation takes in our
development data for our test data
and whatever vector space model you've
developed as its two arguments and it
returns a new version of this input here
with a column for the predictions you
made as well as this value here which is
the spearmint rank correlation
coefficient that's our primary metric
for this unit
here
is the score that i achieved not so good
i'm sure you'll be able to do better and
here's a look at the new account data
frame with that new predict column of
predictions inserted into it
and this is just another baseline here a
truly random system that just predicts a
random score and that's uh even worse
than the simple count baseline again
you'll be able to do much better without
much effort
error analysis i've provided you with
some functions that will allow you to
look at what your system is doing in
terms of the best predictions in terms
of comparing against the human scores
and the worst predictions and i am
imagining that this might help you
figure out where you're doing well and
where you're doing poorly and then you
can iterate on that basis
that brings us to the homework questions
so what we're trying to do here is help
you establish some baseline systems get
used to the code and also think in new
and creative ways about the underlying
problem
our first one is positive point wise
mutual information as a baseline as
you've seen in the materials for this
unit point wise mutual information is a
very strong baseline for lots of
different applications and it also
embodies a kind of core insight that we
see running through a lot of the methods
that we've covered
so it's a natural and pretty strong
baseline and what we're asking you to do
here is simply establish that baseline
here and throughout all of the work for
this
course we're going to ask you to
implement things and in general we will
provide you with test functions that
will help you make sure you have
iterated towards the solution that we're
looking for so you can feel rest assured
that if you have meaningfully passed
this test
then you'll do well in terms of the
overall evaluation and your code is
functioning as expected
next question is similar so again now
we're exploring latent semantic analysis
and in particular we're asking you to
build up some code that will allow you
to test different dimensionalities for a
given vector space input and try to get
a feel for which one is best
so again you have to implement a
function and then there's a test that
will help you make sure that you've
implemented the correct function in case
there's any uncertainty in the
instructions here
next question as i mentioned in the
lectures t-test free weighting is a very
powerful re-weighting scheme it has some
affinities with point-wise mutual
information but it is different
uh and this question is just asking you
to implement that rewriting function
we've given the instructions here you
might also look in vsm.pi the module at
the implementation of pointwise mutual
information because you could adopt some
of the same techniques
i want to emphasize that you don't need
the fastest possible implementation any
working implementation will get full
credit but the code in bsm.pi is really
nicely optimized in terms of its
implementation so you might want to push
yourself
to do something similarly efficient
but again
as long as your function t test here
passes this test you're in good shape
and you don't need to evaluate this
function we're just asking you to
implement it but we're assuming since
i've said that this is a good
re-weighting scheme that you'll be
curious about how it performs in the
context context of the system you're
developing
all right for the final two questions
we're asking you to think further afield
pooled bert representations is drawing
on the material in this notebook here
which is just an exploration of the
ideas from bamasani in all 2020 on how
to derive static representations from
models like bert
and so what we've got here is some
starter code for you and a kind of
skeleton for implementing your own
version of that solution
again we're hoping that this is a
foundation for further exploration for
you
we've got the implementation to do here
and then a test that you can pass to
make sure that you've implemented things
according to the design specification
the final question is also really
exploratory it's called learn distance
functions the idea here is that much of
the code in this notebook pushes you to
think about distance in terms of things
like cosine distance or euclidean
distance
but we should have in mind that the only
formal requirement is that you have some
function that will map a pair of vectors
into a real valued score
as soon as you see things from that
perspective you realize that a whole
world of options opens up to you and
what this question is asking you to do
is train a k nearest neighbors model on
the development data that will learn to
predict scores and then you can use that
in place of cosine or euclidean we've
walked you through how to implement that
there's a bunch of guidance here and a
few tests for the sub components if you
follow our design
again if the test pass you should be in
good shape we're not asking you to
evaluate this directly
but we're hoping that this is a
foundation for for exploring what could
be a quite productive avenue of
solutions in this space
and then finally the original system
this is worth three points this is a big
deal here you can piece together any
part of what you've done previously all
that stuff is fair game you can think in
entirely original and new ways you can
do something simple you can do something
complex
what we'd like you to do here is not
only provide the implementation in the
scope of this conditional so that it
doesn't cause the autograder to fail if
you have special requirements and so
forth but we're also looking for a
textual description
uh and a report on what your highest
development set score was
the idea here is that at the end of the
bake off the teaching team will create a
report that kind of analyzes across all
the different submissions and reflects
back to you all what worked and what
didn't and as part of that effort
these system descriptions and
development scores can really help us
understand um how things played out
and that brings us to the bake off so
for the bake off what you really need to
do is just run this function create bake
off submission
on
your vector space model here it's my
simple one count df that i loaded before
and as a reminder that this is an
important piece you almost also need to
specify some distance function
so the idea is that here my bake off
would be the simple submission where i'm
just doing account data frame and
euclidean as my distance and when i run
this function it creates a file cs224u
word relatedness fakeoff entry and
you'll just upload that to gradescope
we'll give some instructions about that
later on and that will be evaluated by
an automatic system
and that's it